[Music]
blah blah blah Matt Rife is here
finally Matt Rife is here and I'm just
going to start off on a very weird note
go for it we've we know each other a bit
we're not close enough to do what I'm
about to do oh boy which is I
maybe you can help me with this
I just took a pregnancy test for real
and
and it's mats and that's final Jerry
Springer just died I'm taking over
you're one bit of success and they try
to take you down do you know what this
is okay yeah you're supposed to I
haven't taken a lot of pregnancy tests
in my day in fact like almost none I did
pee on it so don't look at this do you
have covet or no like what's
it normally it would say pregnant or not
pregnant it's it's a picture of a book
it's like bitch read a book before you
have a kid
do you see that yeah there's a like a
book on it
I'm very confused like bitch you need
the Bible I think it's a picture of the
Bible
it's supposed to say on the manual yeah
it's supposed to just say pregnant or
not pregnant
I didn't really read the manual which
probably means I shouldn't have a kid at
any capacity
um do you know what the book means
get ready to tell good night stories
bedtime story I don't I don't know
that's that's such a mixed message isn't
that kind of wild I mean you should get
your money back are you gonna take
another one I don't know but not this
point right now I don't need to be
yelled at
I don't need to be told bitch you're
illiterate you can't read either is this
your first pregnancy test
um I just started feeling okay I think
that when I put weight on I'm like must
be pregnant haven't had sex in months
but definitely pregnant you haven't been
dumped in recently I haven't I know
that's kind of the worst way you could
say that but oh sorry I know I'm sorry
I'm sorry no I have and well this is
actually oh this is something
something that I want to start talking
with you about and if you don't want to
talk about it we'll cut it out okay
maybe
um uh is I'm dating a younger guy how
young he's
11 years younger than me
which is your thing do you want me to do
math right now how old are you
40.
[Laughter]
you're touring now you're gonna look 65
in no time and I can't mean it oh my God
you're gonna have gray hair in 20
minutes I might I might get a beard
someday and I might I might get hot who
knows I've been many men's beards I'll
be your beard that's the nicest thing
anyone's ever asked wow oh so he's 29
where did you meet him at a show that's
not what always happens is it did he
approach you he would come he came to a
couple shows and would kind of like
hover and I thought he was like a
Romanian orphan he's Romanian no but I
thought he was
his eyes are not close together
his eyes are like definitely running
away from each other are they wonky yes
yeah spooky at best yeah Willy Wonka
um now is it did he come with like a
group of people that you knew were
coming or he just happened
that's scary no I mean did you invite
him to the shows wait may I well I post
about it I don't send evites out to
people to come to shows this is a public
event okay I'm not but here but this is
everyone's like that's so creepy why if
a man comes to a woman's comedy show or
thinks she's funny we immediately decide
he's a serial killer
something about a guy going I mean even
if a guy goes to a grown man's comedy
show by himself it's a little bit creepy
but to go by yourself and go I'm gonna
Nestle into my seat by myself and just
watch this woman emasculate Matt like
yeah that's a certain fetish but let me
ask you if you see a girl on a podcast
or on or something that you like and she
was a performer or would what else would
you I would DM her if you wanted to
shoot your shot but but I wouldn't just
show up I don't look through my DMs it's
just fucking I can't really look through
a bag
no like who am I gonna hire to be like
hey can you look at all the dicks in my
DM so after he came to multiple shows he
just approached you in one of the
hallways or something no he just would
kind of like bring always bring me like
kind of a gift that was very like a
really deep cut if this didn't alarm you
at all
15 years in The Comedy Store hallway
with comedians you think anything scares
me at this point Matthew I guess that's
true as long as he didn't pull his dick
out I guess it's not like the worst
thing that has happened in the comedy
community I think it's funny when guys
pull their dicks out sorry
I'll stop doing it I'm not I'm not
terrified but that's just me I'm a
female like I think it's funny
I love dick pics I think it's funny when
guys get your airdrop on
perfect
you just drove to my house you have all
people know there's no Wi-fi here
oh I'm on it
I'll mail it to you thank you for coming
out I feel like um we know each other
kind of yeah
I Feel Like Comics like you kind of
instantly really know each other very
well even though you don't but we
started to work together during like the
pandemic outdoor shows and you're always
very sweet and I can't thank you enough
for coming to do those this is how you
know I like you I drove to Venice to do
your show oh my God it was a nightmare
thank you I agree thank you I agree and
no because I remember it was the first
time I had a topo Chico
I don't even think I've had a triple
chica what is that that sparkling water
yeah
okay I've been with you for the last 20
minutes he doesn't drink caffeine he
doesn't drink Sparkling Water
that's why you don't drink calm what's
next I mean maybe it's I'll gargle it a
little bit but I'm not gonna swallow
like a monster look at all these
followers the only thing worse than come
I think is Evian water evian's fucking
disgusting wait that is so weird that
you say that because I've always thought
it had a flavor it's gross but if a girl
says that you're nuts if a guy says that
you're like that's true no no if if
anybody can back me up on Evian water
tastes like an old person put in their
mouth
and put it right back it is like
disgusting it's ashy Ash it's ashy water
wow I never thought of it like that it
does come from the Alps of Swift I mean
all Waters just I don't where what's
your preferred water like a Fiji Water
okay oh okay yeah or whoever wants to
sponsor my shows do you do energy drinks
well I'm kind of into this Monster
Energy Drink really I love that it's a
society we just you have to say this no
actually no no but I do
June shine is I do love and kill what
liquid depth what am I saying my
favorite water is liquid death it's
supposed to be on this desk right now
where is it
[Music]
um I love that it's a society we just
started saying taurine
what's touring taurine is what's in Red
Bull and in this stuff taurine it'll say
like extra taurine what is it though
taurine is okay so you have no caffeine
in your life
a little bit of green tea that's about
it okay tell me I need to know what do
you uh I have horrific insomnia so if I
have any caffeine on top of that I won't
sleep for like a year I also that's why
you get a horrific Lunesta addiction is
that a like Vanessa works yeah oh I
don't really take it anymore I used to
have same insomnia have you gone to
someone about it or yes I went to two
sleep doctors you know what these
motherfuckers told there's no such thing
as a sleep doctor
this is a sleep doctor slash acting
teacher in L.A man I don't know each
other that well but I just discovered
that I really like him as a person you
have this thing that I think I have to
in the beginning where people are
surprised how much they like me when
they meet me oh thank God it's a weird
it's a weird compliment yeah I think
people expect me to be a douchebag no
they're just like it's just simple
they're like he's really handsome he's
probably an arrogant dick and then
you're super humble and cool and there's
a reason you are who you are but like I
was ugly for so long or people want to
hate you because they're just like
there's got to be something wrong with
this guy yeah I mean I'm sure this was
the majority of your career yeah I think
I may people are I don't know or people
or maybe it's just my stand-up misled
people because I was so cunty I think
for so long because you're hot and funny
and a woman like three things pleasure
you can head out yeah well we need it
absolutely off another sleep doctor
fantastic sleep doctor so who is Dr
Cosby oh God I wish that would actually
got some solutions one tried to sell me
a light
and the other person like a like a
flashlight no like like a um like a UV
light that was supposed to like help me
wake up and like it was supposed to
emulate sunlight basically because to
piggyback on the other doctor they both
basically were like you don't need any
medication you don't need anything like
that you don't need any help what you
need is a proficient sleep schedule I go
do you realize that will never happen
for the rest of my life yeah we work
till what sometimes two in the morning
and then we have such an adrenaline High
we come home we try to relax a little
bit we fall asleep around four or five
you gotta go through your tags go
through your tags absolutely maybe you
smoke a little bit of your devices at
the end of the night yeah yeah and then
you'll be up at what 10 a.m for meetings
auditions whatever it may be there's no
time to like and they have to travel
once you fly out of LAX to go to the
east coast you're getting up at 3am to
catch a 5 a.m flight yeah I can't sleep
on planes either so I land two shows
it's just a mess you're in a different
time zone you don't get to settle into
your bed most of the time
a dead person me really just same same
same here's what I'll say is that I
fought with my insomnia for so long and
I learned a couple things number one
there's a theory called the night
watcher Theory and I'll give you a book
from downstairs in my library with all
the fake books I've never read about how
essentially when we were in tribes
thousands of years ago we lived in
tribes right and there was always going
to be a couple people that stayed up at
night while everyone else was sleeping
and they were the night Watchers right
so they stayed up to you know I heard a
rustling of Leaves we got to get up
there's a lion there's this right they
stayed up at night and they were
nocturnal the night Watchers bred with
the night Watchers and epigenetically
were imprinted to sort of come alive at
night be more awake at night and then
um just I know some people that cannot
fall asleep before like two three four
in the morning I was wondering
my 10 pm is about 2 A.M crazy so it's
just your circadian rhythms up I come
alive at that time same I'm so I do most
of my work after I get done with shows
around two three in the morning it's
also great because no one's texting you
yeah there's no no news to refresh oh my
God I'm so happy you understand I've
dated so many girls who are morning
people and they're like I don't
understand why you can't wake up it's
lazy that you don't wake up in the
morning like you don't understand I'm
getting so much work done while you're
asleep also you know how basic it is
that you do wake up early in the morning
but everyone yeah
to go wait in line at Alfred I can't
stand a morning girl I just want to wake
up and start my meditation I want to be
up before the sun because I want the
world to know like I am the light of the
world
well it's also I mean most people kind
of I guess have to like we're
technically kind of supposed to wake up
with the sun and go to sleep when the
Sun goes down unless you're a night
watcher but I've also heard theories
before where I might butcher this
somebody might understand it better than
I do there's like a certain study or
maybe it's a specific group of people
that says we're actually supposed to
sleep in four hour increments twice
throughout the day interesting so I'm
like who knows if any of us are correct
it's called Joe Rogan he'll know oh shit
yeah his number yes I do he changes it
every 20 minutes
um but uh have you been to his Club I
have twice do you like it it's amazing
really it's amazing I mean it was the
mothership it's like you know it's funny
I was I I almost texted him the other
day and I thought better of it because
it's taken so long for it to
show up yeah I was like you should have
called it the comedy fathership
I thought it was never gonna show up but
once he did it it it he put so much
thought into it and so much effort into
it you know and I remember when everyone
was kind of like is this gonna happen is
he really gonna do it he bought one
piece of property that ended up being
the site of this crazy sex cult uh what
is it called not wild wild country uh
it's called holy hell that's the name of
the documentary Epstein's Island not
Epstein no stop talking about my summer
camp
um very triggered uh I'm very sensitive
about Epstein Island a lot of my friends
died trying to swim there man
um
fully drowned
it's very sensitive there hadn't been
one person who went to Epstein's Island
was like whoa dude I'm just here to jet
ski like there has to be somebody who
was like I'm actually not trying to fuck
well because I actually think to me like
whenever this is how I don't see myself
as a naive person but I'm very literal
in a lot of ways so I think about like
sex addiction which is something I've
learned a lot about try to be humble to
is something that identifies is it
having an addictive personality not to
substances or sex or whatever but um yet
I don't know
um and I'm so happy we're friends now
right what in case the 29 year old
doesn't work out perfect
you're trying to find a cause for your
symptoms and you stumble down a
Tick-Tock Rabbit Hole full of
questionable advice from so-called
experts the irony given I was on Tick
Tock asking how much time I had left on
my biological clock how many more ticks
and talks there are better ways to get
the answers you want and there's better
ways to get the care you deserve from
trusted professionals and not random
people on the internet ZocDoc helps you
find expert doctors and medical
professionals that specialize in the
care you need and deliver the type of
experience you want no more Dr roulette
or scouring the internet for
questionable at best reviews with ZocDoc
you have a trusted guide to connect you
to your favorite doctor that you haven't
even met yet millions of people use
zocdoc's free app to healthcare being
free in any capacity
Tada you're gonna find and book a doctor
in your neighborhood who is patient
reviewed and fits your needs and
schedule just right sock talk is the
only free app that lets you find and
book doctors who are patient reviewed
take your insurance are available when
you need them and treat almost every
condition Under the Sun go to zocdoc.com
Whitney and download the ZocDoc app for
free then find and book a top-rated
doctor today many are available within
24 hours at zoc zoc
doc.com Whitney sockdock.com
Whitney I do want to talk about your
dating an older gal which we all know
about but I'm fascinated because a lot
of guys I know are now going like maybe
it's because they wake up early or want
to date older women what is that
um
no I think you guys miss pubes I think
you miss them it's uh no definitely not
um
it's a maturity thing for me it's really
I gotta say
I have lots of younger girlfriends that
are um uh comics and stuff whatever but
they're just you know the number of
times there's like I left my ATM card in
the machine I'm just like
no I can't do it you have to have your
shit together I can't stand anybody
who's like I've just been so
self-responsible since I was 17 like
I've lived on my own since then and my
family has no did you leave Ohio at that
time yeah I graduated high school early
at 17 and I moved out here like two
weeks later crazy and I was on the couch
for the next two but you were already
like I know I'm gonna be an Entertainer
I have been doing stand-up for two years
by that already yeah in Ohio yeah and
then who did you what did you see like
growing up that made you think uh it was
Chappelle and Dane Cook actually uh my
mom won tickets on the radio to see Dane
Cook live in Nationwide Arena in
Columbus it was like nosebleed seats
obviously but we went and I was like
fuck this is like this is what I want to
do I started like the next year I opened
for him once on it might have been that
tour in Florida really and this is a
time where and I'm I'm so glad that you
came up watching him because he was
someone that got such a necessary like I
don't think it's gonna happen I think
you're getting it a different way and
and different people are getting things
there's not one way to get famous as a
comedian anymore Reach people but I
think everyone was so jealous that he
like hacked the system by sort of like
he was just the first to do it well yeah
it was like every like well everyone
else was smoking weed and playing video
games he was just dming people
connecting with his fans he actually
like cared about you know about them
whatever and um I remember opening for
him on the road and it was like 20 000
seats or whatever and when he came out
it was so loud oh yeah it was like it
was like seeing like a rock star and
people had signs they were holding
similar concept we just started doing
theaters about maybe two months ago
I'm sorry because I traveled with my
friends yeah so I'm sorry no it's cute
it's sweet but it's just like it's this
is you're so humble and such endearing
thank you I I just remember like you
used to a comedy club and you know what
an uproarious Comedy Club sounds like
it's great yeah but I had never
headlined a theater before and it was
the the vet in um
wrote uh oh God conquered maybe
conquered New Hampshire and it's two
it's only two thousand seats which isn't
a massive theater but it's a theater
Amber walking out on stage and it was
just like it actually hurt my fucking
ears and people had signs it was insane
it was like
whenever I watch Comics do theaters they
would always um do like the Casual
saunter across stage waving a little bit
or whatever I always thought that was
kind of pandering but like I found my I
found myself naturally like taking that
moment and being like I couldn't believe
and they held the Applause until I got
to them it was it was just insane I
didn't expect it though what's that I'm
kidding oh absolutely they are coming
hyped the fuck up they're they're so
annoying in the best way but you know
that's so cool about like when I go on
the road and there's like so much
excitement you're like oh like really
because doing stand up in La I kind of
took a break from just working on new
stuff because I feel like everyone in La
is on Edibles yes and you go to do shows
at La clubs now and they're all just
like everyone's micro dosing mushrooms
yes in indica and you're like stand-up's
meant to be a little bit of alcohol like
you're supposed to have a little anger
grit to it yeah the audience is supposed
to be a little on point and like I don't
like I don't like La shows I don't like
New York shows I don't like Chicago
shows I don't like San Francisco shows
well I know there's I know those are the
main Market it's but they are not the
best audiences yeah Chicago I feel like
is I've I've been you know like that
what venue were you doing do you
remember oh God where were you no it was
Chicago it was just uh it was just
Zanies there but we're not in Chicago
yeah see if you're are doing the Chicago
theater that's insane I know I'm so
excited that's gonna be a little bit
different because I feel like when four
day in there so I've been on the stage
before and it was crazy just don't do
Ayahuasca at a comedy show don't do
mushrooms
over saturation of entertainment like in
LA there's a million things to do people
have been to a hundred comedy shows it's
not as special you go to where was I
just saying yeah fantastic shows Des
Moines Iowa yeah always where Ashton
Kutcher is from actually yeah the shows
were fantastic because nothing happens
there they are so excited that a person
they know is coming to their City I just
did uh they're so great a row of Canada
shows and I went to a Saskatchewan how
was it it was
four fucking connections we get there
but it's like 3 500 seats
ah it was what it was the best feeling
because they're so grateful that you're
showing up so you also get a lot of
people that you know I think when you're
only doing comedy for your people
sometimes it feels more like a rally and
you're like am I getting more than I
deserve like I don't want anything I
don't oh no I I prefer I still much
prefer to perform in front of audiences
who have no idea who I am because I
think if you go to markets like that
that are a little more like esoteric
parts of the country like you're gonna
get someone like yeah this
yeah let's just see and then you and
then you get to win
it's like so much more satisfying
because a lot of my as younger women
they're like I could say anything
[Laughter]
so wet and you're like that's I'm doing
the setup babe like can we can you just
wait a second well so let me ask you
something now that you have so many
younger female fans you have like are
you dating can you date do you feel like
if you date you're gonna lose them no
I'm not worried about that because I
I've never been one to sacrifice my
personal happiness for the success of my
career I believe if I just keep working
hard and keep doing what I'm doing
nothing should ultimately affect it
um and also I
nobody ever believes this but like I
would love to settle down I would love
to believe that because I look like a
fuck boy and I'm gonna and I'm in a
different city every other day in front
of thousands of women who would like to
date me or something else
um so not that to me at all well I mean
how often do people really get a chance
to get to know you you know yeah I think
maybe Comics just kind of feel out
Comics or something like there's a
little more of uh and I think all of us
because we're gravitating towards this
profession I think we all want
consistent love at least the healthy
ones because we're so inconsistently
loved by strangers absolutely and I'll
play that up a little bit on stage I
mean you know your stage Persona is
different than how you are in real life
you couldn't keep that up your entire
life you'd go fucking insane and you'd
be exhausted can I tell you one of the
saddest things I've ever seen or like
one of the most pivotal things like you
know and I'd love to ask you what yours
are like sometimes in your career or
personal life whatever something happens
it's a small thing that you witness that
if someone told you uh hey don't do this
one thing you won't be happy you
wouldn't be able to understand the
advice but if you just see someone
suffering from the consequence you can
get it for so I was opening for this um
big kind of very successful Club act
comic when I was probably 22. he was
much older and his act was very much
about being married and his wife being a
nag and he just would kill the guy with
murder but he had been divorced for like
two years and right before he went on
stage I was backstage with him I got off
the host goes on he's about to go on
stage he pulls a wedding ring out of his
pocket
goes
puts it on his finger goes on stage
and I remember if someone had told me be
the same person on stage as you are off
stage it will be a prison if you lie you
know don't pretend you're married if
you're not and vice versa I remember
going I got it right away I was like God
with the universe whoever put that in my
path I was like I will never lie on
stage and get trapped into some getting
fans that'll only like me if I'm you
know all his fans were married couples
and he felt like he couldn't be single
on stage or he was betraying them or
couldn't write new material without that
that's so painful it was brutal sad but
I'm so glad you already have that like
I'm just gonna be the person I am like
yeah and it's come through
self-experience more than actually
witnessing somebody else do something
like that actually I've I've caught
myself
um going on stage and being like Oh I'm
just gonna phone this in and do this set
and this these jokes in that order and
that was so not fun to me and I was like
I don't ever want to not have fun on
stage and that's also why I do a lot of
crowd work like I want this is something
I know I do well and it's fun for me and
it's organic
um do you find now that you are doing
the posting the crowd work videos that
people want to participate okay it's a
fucking nightmare with me oh my God
seeing the crowd work videos I was like
I guess I could do that then I was like
well then people are going to show up
trying to get in the or yeah heckling
and because they think they're helping
before before we get into that I just I
did want to reference I wanted to make I
wanted to make sure that like on Tick
Tock a lot of the stuff that goes viral
is like I used to have a joke actually
in this special where it's like I take
my belt off seductively with one hand
right and that went so viral on Tick
Tock that now people are screaming that
at shows all the time and it's very
annoying take your belts off with one
hand yes at least seven times all right
well at least you don't walk down the
street and have people go oh yeah
get to their fucking Tesla horns
and then I'm like why what is wrong with
you like I'm like this person has a
disability I'm like oh no they're
quoting me fuck people start yelling
your folks out at you oh yeah and you're
just like excuse me flattering well no
they're just like squirting in the thing
and I'm like uh security and they're
like no that's your joke and I'm like oh
that's right you have to make that
choice like that guy saw talking about
his marriage brings people on his side
and he knew he could capitalize that
make money off of it and gain fans off
of it right but it cost him that that
emotional difficulty we have to make
that decision you could play sometimes
somebody else Bop up on you on the
street you could go
and play into it and that's your day and
they go yes this is her thing and now
I'm an even bigger fan right I always do
I always like but to an extent right it
would drive you fucking when guys say
during sex that's a bummer oh my god
when they dump inside me and yell bop
bop inside it's always rough yeah it
doesn't sound good does it
still kind of hot a little bit but I
realized I was like there was one a
millisecond it popped in my head I go
wow if I really just played it into this
fuck boy thing of like taking my belt
off on stage through a bit or whatever
I'm like these shows would be up Roars
the energy would be Rock Star level I
would have so many more female fans
you're not in a boy band though and
that's exactly I go what is what Pride
would I have left you know so I I would
not be worth the fact that you would
never be able to make eye contact with a
comedian walking down the hallway of the
company I already can barely do that so
that's that's not that big of a gift
because as you walk down there they're
taking their belt off oh gross so it's
like yeah there's been certain moments
where I've had to just make decisions on
how how I want to be known for my career
it's like obviously yeah people give me
shit for the way I look all the time
it's like oh because you are I don't
know I can't relate to that at all
what's it like of course you can what's
it like people go oh you're attractive
you can't be funny if it's not possible
that's not why people are coming never
sure it is it's like well then what's
all this laughter yeah combi's democracy
my favorite thing is when I see a room
full of women who brought their
boyfriends and the show starts with a
boyfriend like this and the girlfriend
like this and 30 minutes in the
girlfriend is like this and the
boyfriend is like this I love that like
my dude I go oh my God I'm good at
comedy thank God yeah yeah thank God
women are offended by me I must be funny
I have to be doing something right yeah
so if I can get Best of Both Worlds I
guess the the perfect uh percentage it's
never easy to date regardless so I hate
to be the person like has it gotten
harder since you've gotten famous kind
of thing but like do you find a
different what are the obstacles now and
like what are you looking for times the
biggest obstacle because I'm
that's kind of where I draw the line on
it and Mohegan Sun is coming up so we're
fucking pushing it
um s-o-n um time schedule wise because
what younger guys want to date me I'm
kind of like oh my God they're into like
a like a like a woman no they just know
they don't have to work yeah absolutely
wait a second you're just don't think I
can get pregnant
it's so hot purple hurtful love it
just time scheduling because I don't
like half half-assing a relationship
when when I date somebody I love to be
in like a massive Crush where it's like
I I can't wait to talk to you all day I
want to be annoyed by myself by how much
I'm texting I like to be a little
irresponsible with how much I'm Into You
right yeah but do you feel like you
overdose on people like I feel like
sometimes I'm like oh God is this gonna
inevitably like no I'm I'm so present in
How I Feel which is why I fucking I hate
the term love bombing so much yeah
because the alternative the opposite of
Love bombing is playing games love
bombing to me is when you just even if
it's early on if there's a if there's an
appropriate way to go about being like
hey I I really do like you if I want to
show up on the the third to fifth date
with a a funny gift or something like
that if it's a joke and it's funny and
I'm giving it to you because I think
we'll have the connection via the
context of it yeah I don't see the same
I don't think there's any problems you
buy one girly nuva ring on the fifth
yeah but it's also the main things I
hear from women
um is like they complain there's no
romance anymore and then they complain
men are love bombing it's like what is
it I I think that's something that that
people like just in the rear view mirror
have to say happened in order to say
like oh that was toxic yes maybe he just
realized you were whack and stopped yeah
but he loved Bobby it's like no I think
he genuinely wanted to
romance you yeah he wanted he wanted a
romance and then he got to know you in
your garbage yeah absolutely you also
did it though too because this guy that
came to my shows brought me gifts and
we're like this guy must be a psycho and
it's like wait a second like before the
internet that's how you had to meet a
girl absolutely you would just show up
at her job
because his thing was like I'm not gonna
DM you like that's creepy and psycho you
know he's like I don't want to be one of
like all these guys just sending you
weird messages and he's right and then
he kind of just was like showed up and
he just kept showing up and I ca I mean
he was on my security list I like he was
being watched and then I kind of
I was like I have a stalker which by the
way no one has this no no one's everyone
thinks someone's gonna no you're not
worth going to jail for the narcissism
of thinking someone's also if someone
you're I'm sure going to be getting all
this stuff soon like when you're getting
death threats and stuff Gavin debecca
always says like if someone's gonna kill
you they're not gonna give you a heads
up
it's a very good point you're the state
when someone says I'm gonna fucking kill
you that's the safest you can be I
should probably stop uh responding back
to people online then when people say
they want to fight me I've dropped my
tour schedule and comments being like
please come try let's talk about oh
let's go all right
so but you know that's just someone
that's flirting they're flirting
they're flirting I want to Edge the fuck
out of them but do you is that when you
put their head on a curb and kick it
yeah yeah no it's fucking just teeth
right on the curb isn't that curbing or
that's edging what's edging that's
curbing edging you know are you
genuinely packaging is when you fuck for
a long time and don't come well I mean
that's kind of the premise but it's more
like foreplay kind of stuff it was it
would be like if you
if you were blowing a dude I guess you
would kind of like you would play with a
tip a lot you would you would get him so
close and and then not let him come for
a while and then apparently just bite
yeah yeah right but right when you feel
it starts to kind of like yogurt tube
its way to the top you just kind of
clamp it shut and go no no no no no not
yet I just go
I just use it as a microphone
through the back of your head because
it's his trigger worth yeah
so okay so let me ask you something so
if you're gonna pursue a girl how do you
do it or you're dming are you on apps
are you definitely not I'm not on any
apps okay I was on Raya for a minute I
think I still have the subscription so
people still find me on yeah but people
use photos of you as their Riot profile
oh Grinder's the big one my gay friends
will text me all the time yes there was
a time on Tinder where guys would post a
photo of me and them like after shows
that's actually kind of Genius it's
pretty it's a pretty like it just loves
you when people send it it's such a
funny thing to be like I waited in line
to take a picture with Whitney Cummings
at her show like I think Well they um
they don't get that contacts they don't
give that kind they go look how close I
am with our favorite comedian okay but
so that I was on Tinder but not on
Tinder yeah the apps are here's the
problem with apps is like I want to get
to know you right I want some insight
into your life
Instagram gives way more of an Insight
than Tinder would how much do you want
to find out from their social media
versus in person from them
um you know what
that's it's a tricky portion to
proportion to navigate because
I do want to know about my body I do I
know you have such a hot body I don't
want to hear that It's Tricky I don't
think so it's a little tricky I I do
want to know a lot and I also I will
judge off social media because even if
that's not who you are as a person
there's a part of you that allows
yourself to post that stuff well this is
what you want other people you want to
control other people's perception of you
yes and you're trying to bait something
whether it's you want people to think
you're a good person you want people to
think you're fun you want people to
think you're absolutely you want to just
be in the mix yeah and I think and I
there are I I do want to go and look for
red flags a little bit first because
there's something
wow get into it let's get into them I'm
a big lifestyle guy lifestyles are big
red flags girls who go out to clubs all
the time I thought you meant like had
lifestyle brands
is that it that's like the thing now if
you're an actress by 40 like I gotta
have a Lifestyle brand like I haven't
lived a normal life ever do you have a
lifestyle I don't have a Lifestyle brand
I don't what would I do I mean clearly
you need the money I don't know I don't
know
tell anyone how to live their lifestyle
that's what Paul Joe's job didn't she
sell like vagina scented candles uh-huh
how do I get that sponsored by the way I
can
somebody somebody
I can make this smell like my vagina
right now wow here we go here we go it's
like um
smells like money and kombucha that's
that's what my vagina smells like it's
beautiful actually this episode is
brought to you by kariyuma the cool
sustainable sneakers loved by Surfers
and skateboarders they're reimagining
classic sneakers with you and the planet
and mine spring has officially sprung
and we're trading out the boots and the
cold weather kicks and the clogs and the
wet socks for something a little lighter
and brighter crafted with organic cotton
canvas and spring Shades like rose
off-white and green are best seller best
seller okay I feel like I'm hitting my
groove here the best seller is okalo
it's sure to become your staple shoe of
the season and lucky you they just
cleared a 77 000 person wait list with
10 plus colorways bold prints and
collaborations with Brands like Avatar
Pantone and the peanuts there's a pair
for every personality that's what I
wanted check this out the Pantone oh
wait dude I am so go into these sneakers
I'm not even kidding you they go you
know why I love them you don't have to
wear socks with them you don't have to
wear socks with them you can if you want
but like these I've been wearing them
non-stop I've been wearing them on the
plane I've been wearing them on stage
I've been wearing them around the house
it just never ends okay I've gotten so
many pairs of these shoes I'm so
obsessed with them they're so good with
over 33 000 five-star reviews there's no
wonder this Ultra comfy and celeb
favorite style is flying off the shelves
the biggest difference between these
sneakers and your old sneakers Oka is
actually comfortable with custom
designed Cork and memory foam insoles to
ensure a perfect fit carry Uma is a b
Corp certified sustainable sneaker
company they are known for the
reforestation efforts in the Brazilian
Rainforest their co-founders David and
Fernando both grew up in Brazil so this
project is especially close to home for
every pair of sneakers sold carry Uma
plants two trees and they've already
planted over 2 million to date and I
would like to date you both kariyuma
ships all their sneakers free and fast
in the U.S say it offers worldwide
shipping and 60-day free returns they
deliver right to your front door using
single box recycled packaging that is
awesome and for a limited time good for
you listeners can get an exclusive 15
off you heard me 15 off your pair of
carry Yuma sneakers go to carry Uma
c-a-r as in car
iuma.com Whitney to get 15 off that's
carry uma.com Whitney for 15 off only
for a limited time okay so red flags
let's get into it because this is one of
my favorite things I think most girls
and guys
I think I don't think most people go on
social media and take a selfie be like I
want people to think I'm a loser I want
people to think I'm lame I think people
genuinely don't understand yeah how they
come off yes yes
um
we get kind of Lucky with our social
media because it's it's a lot of our
business you know yeah a lot of we get
that kind of leeway but a lot of people
who it's just like personality based we
are trying to get attention we are
trying to steal people's attention from
other eye grabbing shit yes when I dyed
my hair it was very much like people are
scrolling through they're gonna go what
the fuck is that yeah like I I think
that way I'm exactly the same way trust
me you know I don't pull shorts yeah
that's why you wear color contacts that
match your shirt exactly oh I love how
you think that I wear contacts that's so
cute I wear color contacts in one of my
specials no you didn't yes I did yes I
did they're okay so in my defense okay
in my defense because I see how lame
that is I had to wear real contacts but
I kept you've never worn contacts right
I wear regular contacts okay but when
you put them in sometimes it's hard to
like I had never worn them before and I
had to put them in and I kept missing
it's hard to find the eye hole it's hard
to find the eye hole Yeah it's like it's
like when guys are so confused how far
back the pussy hole is I feel like guys
are always confused like they never get
used to how far back it is is I I I'd
say a good 30 of the time I get on top I
go that is and they're like down I'm
like really like so well because it's
like I think all girls like guys are
trying to put in our butts I'm like no I
think they're no we just have no
comments they just are still confu it's
so far I've settled for a belly button
plenty of times absolutely
yeah when you think about how far back
the vagina is it's a it's a I get why I
mean I feel
stressed out for you guys I always want
to be like I will remind a guy just like
um where was I going with that I don't
know keep going on this championship
this is fantastic I feel like now I'm
just trying to make sure I'm normal I'm
like right I mean where is it holds like
in your lower back yes
right
I just I just feel like you need to go
yes it's so far back it's so far back
thank you
um but I forgot where I was going with
that
red flags red flags if her vaginas yeah
giant is right up here that's bad no I
don't want to be able to look into it
from standing in front of you okay
morning person definitely yeah so anyone
with a job is out the thing is I can do
a morning person if you just let me
sleep if you can do your day outside of
waking me don't shame me don't wake me
up no don't don't do not
we're starting our day with your cup of
coffee a vampire she's signing up to
date a vampire guess what Twilight
number one movie ever made nothing
sexier than vampires you don't try to
rebooting it by the way this is who we
are really yeah they're turning into a
TV series please hire me I'm available
we're available we're available to play
incestuous brother and sister yes
absolutely she got bit a little later
than I did but
um but age has no look at that we both
have giant teeth giant like we look
we're both pants like this is I'm this
is a very serious play I love Twilight I
also do I in my first special I did a
whole bit about it I really like to
perform in Dubai and flying back I was
in the back they flew us out first first
first class there was a shower in our is
me Sebastian Maniscalco Ahmed Ahmed Kirk
Fox I want to say Tommy Davidson yeah
and we went out to like do some shakes
like birthday party whatever I almost
got kidnapped it was very flattering but
flew us out showers manicures in our
what do you call it the Hut the the
little Cube Todd um cubicle like first
class pod so it was back coach like the
middle seats in Dubai Emirates it's like
it's like 12 seats I was sitting next to
the three pregnant women okay that could
have given birth at any moment and then
two chickens and then oh and then Dwayne
Perkins what and I was in the backpack
row and I was like so I was like how am
I gonna get through an 18-hour flight
this was before like you remember when I
mean you might still have like you get
so antsy on planes oh yeah I can sit for
two hours on a plane and be happy as if
because there's no Wi-fi no one but back
then I was like I'm falling behind oh of
course I need to get on my phone I'm
losing mom
um and so I watched Twilight once and I
have a very
I think I probably come off pretty
cynical but romance I just some like
that fucking let's die for each other
shit I just was like watched it four
times in a row and wrote a bit about it
God damn I still watch I still watch
Twilight every now and then I had
covered around this time last year and I
sat back and I watched all of them I've
masturbated to clips of Twilight on
YouTube
for real
I don't I don't think I can top that no
I I masturbated to uh Queen latupe's
beauty shop one time two times
there was this one girl in it who had
like this juicy what's it called Juicy
Couture of the velor yeah they're used
both the velor pants or whatever yeah
red flag add that to the red flag list
Juicy Couture
yeah wearing sweatpants during the day
is a little bit of a I need a zipper I
need a button somewhere yeah unless
that's kind of like it's not a pajama
we're not a sleepover yeah be an adult a
little yeah start your day you know me
because I think that when you're
physically sloppy you're gonna be
mentally sloppy also you know it's funny
I'm not with my glasses all the time I'm
like I should get my glasses I actually
get my contacts a rest or rest my eyes a
little bit I wear my glasses I I never
feel like I have started my day if I
wear my glasses I feel like because
that's your at home it's the pavlovian
like the things the rituals you do
because I feel like being a stand-up
it's like we have to self-generate we
have to have discipline but I find if
you're like if I'm home mine is if I
need to write and focus I have to wear a
thong
that wakes you up dude I'm up because
there's times I'll be like Oh I'm just
gonna wear these sweatpants with no
underwear around the house or like
shorts like too casual can't can't two
con and then you put the thong on and
you're like we gotta make some money
retire soon like it motivates you to put
a thong on so if you New Riders block
solution yeah absolutely it's physically
just like all right we're up interesting
yeah there's like a razor blade in my
anus do they really hurt dogs you know
what he's just like if you wore like
regular panties no guy would be like
what though it's the key to my success
really but I will say well no it just
keeps me motivated it keeps me alert
yeah and focused okay you know but also
wearing full butt panties for some
reason feels so
um kinky now really like whenever I put
them on I'm like if a guy's into this
like is this like
why would you be into this it's so like
why not like it just it full butt white
underwear to me feels so kinky for some
reason because it's just so like old
school so old I know I'm like I'm not
gonna bust they're not knickers
full body pervert they're not they're
not a World War II swimsuit they're like
Bloomers at this point I'm like what are
you into like that's some kinky shit
just so often girls do things that they
just don't have to because they think
it's sexy songs heels we've gone so Off
the Grid in terms of uh we can't say
reservation right it came this close uh
it's a reservation anymore off the
reservation I guess it's not great
we're here for a 7 30 Plantation like
what how do you what do you what do you
replace it with
I how do you say that
it's no it's the in reservation like off
the reservation the etymology of it is
an Indian reservation I have casinos
about this yeah yeah absolutely yeah I
have casinos about our relationship yeah
yeah I love I love performing casinos by
the way because you know they have no
police they have their own police force
really and it's just the elders just
pick I have so many casinos coming up
for the rest of this year get a gun I
really
summer's coming and I'm not unless you
manscape yourself
are are you serious I mean let's just
think is your man ready to unveil his
Beach bod our friends at manscaped are
here to ensure his body is ready for the
wild with their game-changing grooming
and hygiene products don't have your man
be that guy at the beach with the Austin
Powers chest hair and and the you know
if he has a little winter dad boob the
least you can do is make sure he smells
nice and is well groomed okay don't
groom children men groom them
groom away manscape is dedicated to
helping men level up their full body
grooming game with the performance
package 4.0 the perfect package 4.0 kit
comes with the essential lawnmower 4.0
waterproof cordless body trimmer and a
ton of other liquid formulations to go
around whether he's trimming his chest
or the treasure chest in his pants this
is the best trimmer on the market
they're trimmer features a ceramic blade
designed to cut hair on loose skin oh
look at that whoa I just
you know when you open an item and it's
already charged that's quality already
Works already charged you open it it's
not and you're like what's that takes
kind of the magic out of it
foreign
look at that ah does it it's good on on
loose skin it's gonna reduce grooming
accidents thanks to Advanced Skin safe
technology their products can also be
used for females as well and trust me I
need it literally no one likes nose
hairs so their package also comes with
the weed whacker 2.0 which is a total
Game Changer you also get two free gifts
the shed travel bag a 39 value and the
patented high performance reduced
chafing manscaped boxers
what more could you ask for I get 20 20
that's a lot off free shipping with the
code Whitney at manscaped.com that's 20
off plus free shipping with the code
Whitney at manscape.com having the right
tools for grooming is essential do
yourself and your man a favor and help
him upgrade his self-care you know what
go
groom someone
as long as they're of age groom them
threw them all day long a very Pro
grooming is someone who was groomed as a
child
whoa now I'm nervous how are the
audiences at casinos though really yep
it depends on which ones but like like
you know on the native reservations that
have casinos that it it's so well run
people are there to be entertained I
always had a theory that half the people
there are down money though when they
get there so they're like right even
they need to laugh great even better
people will leave their kids with you
it's a good point so they can go gamble
I every time I do a casino someone pukes
in their hand and just holds it in the
front row for like there it's just the
most ride or die motherfuckers that are
there to be entertained like they come
they're gonna do a night they're wearing
a dress that they're in they have a hat
on like it's just like people that are
down to clown I do like that the thing
I'm most looking forward to with those
shows are 21 and up
okay so many of these shows that they
have me doing are 18 and up and I'm like
I do not like Christian Stadium groups
what do you mean they're coming to shows
yeah 18 and I didn't even know you could
do that yeah at theaters and stuff you
can yeah but I do not want I
I I'm 55. well because it's like
it's like the the
um
uh the when they scream
like they it's a high frequency uh
uh a dog whistle I just mean yeah I just
mean like you probably get a lot like oh
it's still worse I hate woo girls at
shows red flags
girls what else you're looking at you're
looking at a girl's IG red flag if she
has a picture in Tulum ever uh
hot girls in L.A go to Tulum like it's
Ralphs yeah Tulum is the mini Epstein
Island um if she has a picture of her at
dinner with 12 other girls because you
know none of them are paying for them
none of them are A different race none
of them not one none of them like not
one you know not one half half asian
girl and it's not a birth it's not a
birthday either it's a it's a it's a
it's a women empowerment night yay which
don't get me wrong I'm all for women in
power I'm gonna ask me to speak but
here's the thing a promoter's paying for
your dinner so get the fuck out of here
I don't even know girls on boats I'm
always like who's boating and my first
special I do like 10 minutes on girls on
boats absolutely none which also you
know that's the main way men kill their
wives a hundred years old oh she slipped
yeah get off the boat yeah absolutely
now if you're going if you're going on a
boat it is beyond implied you have to
fuck this and then for sure you're gonna
fuck this guy or you're going and we're
going to because of the implications
yeah yeah I I have a question which is
when I see girls photos like they're at
dinner whatever who's taking the photos
It's usually the other girlfriend it's
gonna be you uh-uh don't you think
though if you're like who's taking this
photo it's gonna if I sign up for this
it's gonna be me and that's why it's
gonna be my day
it is when I look at a guy's IG I just
go if he's hiking in rock climb and I'm
like I'm gonna have to do that you know
what I mean you're not like doing that
stuff I just you know you have to know
what you're signing up for you don't get
to look at every photo from someone for
the past four years and then be like
this is not what I signed up for this
motherfucker was like oh that's why I I
I keep I date the expectation did you
really yeah strong fingers though I
imagine well that's the thing is they
can't they can't get them wet really
yeah oh I know you went with granite
down the good news what do you have
Granite labia is it Sandstone down there
Jesus Christ it's just jock oh they
can't get their fingers wet because
it'll it'll wet the calluses and then
it'll rip so that's so fast things like
oh they have such strong fingers this is
gonna be great yeah interesting yeah
yeah yeah uh they just use a back screen
no I've dated girls who were influencers
before and I was like we go to dinner
and she's like not not just we grab a
picture of me like okay now you now you
and I'm like I don't want to take you
pulling out the ring light oh my God
some girls have the case where it is a
ring light all right
yeah I'm not interested it's a migraine
okay what else
talking shit about X's I think is a big
red flag
I'll tell you what's a bigger red flag
than that still being friends with your
ex
I can't tell you how many girls I've
dated that the entire relationship they
go I can't block him like we're still
friends and I'm like look you can read
our text message I go this motherfucker
is still flirting I can't block him like
it would create like a weird energy one
of the same frame groups and stuff the
moment we break up I'm blocked so it was
that easy the whole time that's a bigger
red flag I would rather think that means
that she didn't have a strong enough
feelings for that guy I think when you
block someone that means you still have
feelings for them and you either want to
hurt them or be like I can't even look
at this person or I'm gonna
I think that's someone trying to hurt
you I would rather I would rather them
still be wanting to hurt them and not
have any contact with them then like
they're still in their life because
that's the thing if a guy is still in
your life X or not he still wants stuff
or like when things go there's a dry
spell they'll re they'll just exactly
and not not for the right reasons just
for the like this is the Dace in the
hole yes so guys if like they they'll
keep some girls on the back burner or
that just in case absolutely and girls
do the exact same thing
so then you have to break it to them
like you're not friends Sweet Pea oh in
this special I do again about like 12
minutes about how like your guy friend
is not your friend unless you have my
personality I have so many guy friends
it's it's sad I mean you're strong and
intimidating so potentially but still if
you had a moment of weakness and you
said hey Rob or whoever yeah they're
always named Robin every girl has a
guy's name Rob and that's they're the
pro and they are a problem exactly I
don't even need to see any it's Rob's
and Todd's if you had a moment of
weakness and you were like I just would
you fuck me they would go I
ever has asked but there's also I think
I think men ask since when
um I also think that NL I'm bringing
back consent baby let's go that's so
kinky underwear I've literally been
hooking up with women who go you don't
have to be so nice about this and I'm
like yeah I do
I have like if they're like did you
really just ask me if like if if you
could do that I'm like yeah I'm probably
too consensual well it's a tricky one
because it's there definitely was a
spell where and and I may be like not
the best person to weigh in because I do
think guys that are maybe attracting me
or that end up hooking up with like feel
the need to restore the power Dynamic by
like as soon as I got a show on TV guys
went from being like cuddly and sweet
because I was like broke and like a
broken bird and like had nothing and I
was in debt and guys were like the
finger on the cheek to like there was a
kiss on the forehead spit in the face
getting a fish hooked by a baseball
player who wasn't even in the major
leagues wow getting like just fucking
shit I didn't even I had there was a
time where
one time this guy because if a guy
pursues me I always know there's like a
problem
you're literally dating a guy who
pursued you
yeah and there's a problem what's the
problem so many
I don't know it just if a guy comes
after me too hard it feels like a red
flag it's either like you're gay and
like want to learn how to do it
hey kids I'm kind of a gay man's like
dream and or it's someone that I feel
like wants to dominate or tame or maybe
it's not the same anymore or guys are
like I really want a woman that's like
that and then they get
Ed and they're like this is I thought
this would turn off at some point it's
it's an interesting world to navigate
now because you do you do have to be
like you do have to be careful you do
have to be more I mean this is a
ridiculous thing to say like you do have
to be more consensual is that the word
consent because it's consentful or
consensual
respectful respectful you do have read
the room you're a comic though you'll
read the room absolutely
no I'm like just look how do you not
know just look at just see if she's
crying it's consensual I rarely make a
first move it is so rare for me even
like just a kiss I'm sure it is but I'm
like if I if I can't feel that like you
really feel like you want me I'm like I
don't know yeah I don't know and is this
something you've always been or since
you've gotten famous or since like this
sort of no I've always I've always I've
always kind of been that way I've me too
is the last thing I'm concerned about
yeah God yeah
um but there's there was moments that
like
I do enjoy being aggressive yeah that's
but you want it to already be under the
it has to be so obvious that that's what
she wants yeah yeah and that's I
flirtatiously and again read the fucking
room but that that's something that did
kick in when I was like probably 19. I
was like so innocent I had sex with
maybe three people ever and there was
this girl that was so hot and I knew she
was talking to me and another guy that
was like two years older than me and she
was she would always kind of like flirt
around the idea of hooking up or
whatever but I knew she was hooking up
with that guy yeah and I remember I ran
into her four or five years after that
we never hooked up for anything and I go
hey so like
why did you choose that other guy over
me I thought that we looked very similar
I feel like we were on the same age I'll
go why did you like why did you choose
him over me and she was like
he was just more aggressive you were
very much like I want to take you on a
date and I feel like you're so beautiful
and all this kind of stuff and he was
texting me I fucking want you to come
over here yeah and I was like wow some
women are into well that's also at a
very young age I also think there's this
like fear of embarrassing yourself of
course injection yeah like you weren't
asked to prom you weren't I mean what's
a problem yeah yeah dude our high
schools are like a grooming like now
that I look back at the fact that high
school is like force kids to like stress
out for a year about who they're gonna
lose their virginity to it's really
spooky when you think about it the fact
that teachers are like I like that well
yeah they're all like who are we gonna
and then you friendships are broken up
over it like you're stressing out is he
gonna ask me and he's not like it's just
like I can't believe that we put kids
under that kind of stress well they
didn't know what the real world's gonna
be like I mean
it just feels like a Eugenics breeding
program or something it's like it's
teachers are standing around watching
you guys dance knowing you're gonna go
to a hotel and dry hump after like it's
just like a bizarre situation situation
but hold on there was a time but also
what you're saying is you know I think
you're this like new breed of guy that
like the guy that I'm dating has this
like gentleness
and uh sell that on eBay
um retire
um oh of course it came back and hit me
I do that I floss myself with my hair
all the time not with me oh my okay okay
this also isn't my hair whoever's hair
this is I stand with Ukraine but my hair
is Russia it's reservation it is
got this on the reservation I got this
Casino Morongo
um I was hooking up with this guy once I
think there was like a like a kind of
porn maybe that guys were into for a
second I feel like younger guys you're
kind of moving away from porn a little
bit totally right
no I'm vintage baby I got VHS tapes
who's number one y'all are up to no good
yeah that's kind of the best category
why I think there's a couple reasons the
logic number one the nipples are darker
which is like is that a thing yeah
because I never noticed that well when
you have a kid your nipple gets darker
so you can breastfeed so the baby can
find it the nipples are bigger
I also feel like you
kind of know you know she's definitely
not younger you know you know like this
is above board you're not watching so
legal it's crazy we're not watching some
fucking Korean shit that's gonna bite
you in the ass later or you know your
algorithm is not going to be feeding you
like crazy like shit and what was the
other theory about it yeah you don't
have to worry about her because you know
she doesn't feel anything anymore
emotionally I either yeah that's when
whenever whenever I've uh made love to
an older women and she's like oh I'm
like shut up bitch you've done this
before shut no but sometimes you get
more sensitive as you get older you like
know you do know your body more that's a
real thing yeah you know where to
squeeze how to Kegel and honestly
flirtatiously and sexually older women
are better because guys love that
because older women are more straight to
the point if you want to fuck me got
shit to do you're gonna let me know real
quick you're not worried about that like
well I don't I don't want to be like
that girl like no I called you over here
to be that guy yeah yeah
the aggressiveness on your end is so hot
right right I mean I'm not really like
that but in my personal life I'm very
beta because in my professional life I'm
so Alpha that I I need someone to like
be like a very predatory with me
interesting yeah yeah that's why you
like other Comics yeah I don't like them
as people yeah I don't know if I like
them as people or just what choice do I
have I don't put myself in the same
position I've Comics I love they're my
it's like your brothers and sisters
where yeah but you're not hanging out
with them on the daily you can't do it
too much you can't it's too because also
it's like it's a comic it's we're all so
deep we have the scarcity complex if
someone's winning harder than you or you
can feel if you're winning harder than
someone they have a resentment it's all
natural I know and they're so sensitive
and it I also have a really hard time
it's taken me a long time to get really
close to Comics whereas I always felt so
like I was always looking for a family
like these are your co-workers
ultimately but also they're like your
family in a way like who else can you
commiserate with about this stuff yeah
but then I went oh my God I'm spending
too much time with Comics because my
inner monologue is garbage yeah I've
become so negative I'm complaining all
that like I I have a select couple
that's really about it in my friend's
Circle because like select a couple of
people in my friend group who are Comics
but there are also people I've known
since I was like 18 years I've never
heard someone say a bad word about you
really all I ever hear is people saying
because that's the whole thing with
Comics is that we talk shit to someone's
face and nice behind their back so like
yeah there's definitely people who do
not like me another a girl comic the
other day that I flirt with from time to
time we've never done anything but just
like that kind of
texting or whatever she would she just
texts me she goes what did you do what
are you talking about she was like I was
just dating this guy comic and all he
would talk about is how much he hated
the level of success you're getting
right that girl sucks sorry
I mean it wasn't her it was no no the
girl was telling me
she shouldn't have told you that that
means she didn't she's trying to get
your attention like that's like I had
agents call me and be like years ago I
had an agent call me that was like this
is anyone ever got successful and that
people weren't jealous this is like well
it's always it's there's always been
some kind of I guess resentment whatever
because if I wasn't successful I was
young but if I wasn't young I was decent
looking but it's also you I know that if
there's resentment towards you from
anyone like legitimate or whatever it
also you being nice is the fucking the
thing that's the worst about it because
if you were a dick you would be like oh
yeah fuck that guy I mean I haven't met
anybody he's nice like fuck that like
because most people that have gone oh in
order to succeed as a comedian I have to
be negative I have to complain I have to
be nasty I have to hate women I have to
be this kind of guy and wait he's doing
it while also being a good person and
being nice fuck that guy I now what
excuse do I have to not stay uh fucked
in the head because I so many comedians
justify being negative and toxic because
like well that's what's funny yeah and
you challenge that Paradigm and it's
very annoying to a lot of people like
shaking it up well yeah it's like what
the fuck dude no we're negative and
toxic and drink coffee all day and do
drugs and all that and you're like I
don't drink coffee I don't like you're
just doing it
with a big heart and the right way and I
think to people that justified their
behavior as a way to justify like oh no
I'm getting good stories out of this I
have to have a crazy life and you're
just not doing that do we end on you
complimenting me no I would like to read
the negative things people have texted
me yeah let's go no I haven't people
know not to tell talk to me about that
kind of shit because I went through that
where I just got destroyed for trying
hard and being ambitious and like
wanting to succeed and to me now I just
take it as a compliment and you're never
gonna get that kind of criticism or
resentment from anybody who's doing
better than you that's the thing yeah
and it's just kind of like it's also
it's like you know it's Neil Brennan
said to me once he goes if I was a
comedy manager I would just go into
comedy clubs ask all the comedians who
they hated and sign them damn damn yeah
I mean but also comedians hate sugar
cookies like Gary Goldman did 40 minutes
on hating sugar cookie it's like we can
comedians can criticize anything why
wouldn't it be each other damn that's a
good point you know wow it's like you'll
hear comedians complaining for 40
minutes about airplane food like it's
like that's what we do yeah we find we
find flaws in everything we're sensitive
babies that's what we do for a living
it'd be weird if someone was the fact
that people were talking about you just
means exactly what's happening is
happening and the fact that you cracked
like Tick Tock is really annoying to
people I don't get it either it's still
weird yeah no but it's just kind of like
huh and that's my favorite thing about
it is people were like oh we saw he's
like a tick tocker I'm like you know all
I post on takes like a stand-up right
yeah but they have to find some reason
to think about what you do when you
judge someone it's to make yourself feel
better that you don't have that thing
that's lame it's your way of saying like
if I had done that I would have
succeeded but I'm gonna make it my idea
I'm mad that they did a thing before
yeah they just like they tried hard and
they won whereas I'm gonna justify me
like fuck dick dog I don't know that's
just bullshit it's like it's just like a
fear of being vulnerable and you went
for it and that's like just it's just
exposure at the end of the day also
Comics don't buy tickets no they do not
no so I'll listen when you're buying
tickets I'll hear your feedback yeah and
I do if people like write comments like
I've been to five shows and I'm like I'm
listening to your criticism and I will
say that's the most powerful thing about
any success on social media is you go
Hollywood other Comics none of them
matter the power is entirely in the
people so if I can just keep my fans
pleased and happy and continue to grow
and grow with me then it's like that's
that's all I need I'm gonna have to take
that belt off
I hate you okay I'm not going to keep
you any longer because I know you have
to be somewhere um at 5 15. okay Matthew
Stephen Rife this is the special that
got taken down real quick but then put
back up uh yeah and people made such a
big deal out of it more than it was I I
made a big deal because I was genuinely
frustrated that I I promoted it to come
out at this exact time on this exact day
so people were anticipating it yeah and
it was just a chaotic day of getting of
half of it happening it was a travel day
it was a nightmare so we finally
uploaded it and it got flagged we we
bought music rights for it I spent
thousands of dollars on for a specific
song that should have been whitelisted
and cleared the rights and everything
and uh it got flat Man I Feel Like a
Woman by Shania Twain
I thought that would have been so good
who's gonna be the first trans comic to
do that who's gonna be the first trans
comment to come out today I will pay for
utilization that's so smart
they flagged it for the song rights and
it was uh they flagged it for um even
though you bought the song yes and for
it was like something to do with the
content but you guys are not only fans
baby yeah I know solid plug dude I'm
telling you I want to do anything
special they like flagged it to a point
where like every person who was gonna
watch it was gonna have to sign in with
a YouTube account and prove that they
were 18 or older to watch it which which
just kills it in the YouTube algorithm
because none of your fans are over 18.
no they are not no they're not oh God so
it was yeah it was a nightmare but then
like we just took it down they didn't
take it down we took it down because we
were like this is stupid No One's Gonna
Be able to watch it oh yeah yeah so we
took it down I contacted the music
company and they were like hey we'll be
right on it so and we also were like
well
a lot of YouTube they flag stuff in the
first 30 seconds so instead of starting
the special how I wanted to to to start
it I filmed a 13 second or a 30 second
buffer I felt at a comedy club I was
like what can we do and we just went on
stage when everybody left and filmed a
30 second buffer was being like hey
thanks for coming to watch the special
first 30 seconds is what gets so clean I
don't I don't I don't curse I don't do
anything that should be flagging the
first 30 seconds no problem
they didn't Flag the song or anything
after that smart yeah and now we're at
like I think like 5.6 million in a month
it's so funny about Comics how the first
it's like the just the first 30 seconds
you can't say fuck shit and we're like
uh well in all fairness the first word
in the intro to the special is fuckers
is the first thing it's a it's a sketch
it's not like first word no good to be
here no it's a sketch with the f word is
the first word you had was like that's
you know I understand that that's fine
but you know you just had to adapt all
right you have somewhere to be and I'm
not gonna keep you what thank you
um okay uh don't write elephants
um let me ask you your tour you're on
tour now you're about to your kind of
cities yes we have a major tour
announcement coming out uh June
no I shouldn't make fun of you about it
Whitney should not make fun of you about
things like that I you don't talk in
first person and even say ah it's it's
so much healthier that way give me time
I say that too sometimes and I'm like
should I am I minimizing myself is this
like a self-deprecation like it's it is
that it's a team effort I still live in
an apartment we'll see how things change
when I get a house four hours outside
the city like you do I just four hours
to get here
totally worth the drive it's a beautiful
beautiful dresses
Mosaic is it the church that what is the
church just died since you live next to
it it's literally if Hyde was in heaven
like it's just it's just influencers and
promoters like it's the first church
where you get there and they're like how
many bitches you got with you like how
many it's it's kind of full right now we
gotta wait for some people to come out
to bring her church it's a bringer
Church exactly the pastors are so cool
they're like yo the devil's a pussy
right
fuck the dab they try to be so cool all
the choir singers are trying to get
contracts Mary was a dime let's be
honest
yo Jesus hung out with hookers and we
hang out with influencers we are in the
spirit you know we've got a lot of
followers Jesus you know what else does
rose from the dead my dick it's like
what this is doesn't feel like a realtor
no one in that church is getting into
any kind of Heaven oh yeah dude fucking
LA's got all these like weird little
like mini Scientology people that like
couldn't figure out this couldn't like
finish the application for Scientology
because there were two dogs because they
were like on fentanyl or whatever they
go to these other churches that are just
like it's like an Abercrombie and Fitch
like it's like don't think like when you
walk so douchey my ex goes there and I'm
like uh she's trying to get me to go
with her and I I can't do I don't think
God is in that building no I don't think
God is there no God's not subscribing to
your 3.99 a month that you're trying to
plug at like everyone in church is doing
IG lives like Ed sure like yeah it's so
bad it's so now I want to go you want to
go now I want to go now I'm in you just
sold it for me had I known it was like
this I'd be a social experiment I'm in
um okay thank you for coming sorry um it
was far I love you um go see Matt on
tour you're already going to it's
probably already sold out he's the best
we're adding a bunch of dates at the
beginning of June yes and watching
specials on YouTube
mattrife.edu that's not the website do
not go to that company there we go
[Music]
all right
foreign